What if my word doesn't match my company's word?
So I got a great question, a number of times.
The first time it came up was in Malaysia
when I was doing the conference.
I believe that everybody has one word that connects them
that defines them.
It’s a one word biography and when you figure out what that one word is
it helps make all decisions in your life a lot easier.
It helps your marketing decisions easier
it helps partnership decisions easier
every decision in your business
and in your life becomes easier
when you know what you stand for
So mine is BELIEVE
and when I’m creating new content for my website
for Twitter, for Facebook
when I’m making these videos
it has to be about believe
because that’s who I am and it makes me happy
and it makes me excited and it drives me.
You know, I want to see what I create
and say “I’m proud of that”
and not just be creating it to try
to get lots of views.
I actually like everything that I’m making.
So I got a question in Malaysia
at the conference somebody asked
“You know, what if, you know
so I’m working on a… I work at a company
and I’m working on their social media campaign
but what if, you know
my word doesn’t match the company’s word?
What do I do?”
And it’s a tough question.
You know, I don’t like giving advice to employees
because I usually end up making them become entrepreneurs
but what I would advise you to do
when you’re thinking about working with other people
you may not always find everybody
has exactly the same word on your team
or in your circle at the job you’re at.
So for example, mine is BELIEVE.
Jason who does a lot of work with me
his word is RISE.
Rich who does a lot of work with me
his word is INSPIRE.
And so, these are not
it’s not exactly BELIEVE but they’re sister words, right.
That’s the reason why I can get along with them
because they have words that are not exactly the same
but very complementary.
And so if you’re working at a company
and your word is very complementary to
what the company stands for
then it’s going to be a good fit
you know, you’re going to be happy there
you’re going to like the people there
you’re going to able to create marketing campaigns
that will mean something and be important.
If you’re working at a company
that doesn’t stand for anything
or whose values are not aligned with you
or whose one word doesn’t match
is not even close to what yours is then you’re, you know
probably not going to have a good time
working at that company
And you know, no marketing plan is going to save you
and you’d be better off finding a different company
that does match your values
or starting your own thing, you know.
My voice is jumping all over the place.
I’m sick as a dog
I’m running a fever.
Anyway, this is important.
I wanted to get it out.
So that’s my advice if you’re word does not match your company’s word.
Believe.
For those of you watching, you liked the video
thumbs-up below.
Let me know what you think. Leave a comment underneath.
You can wish me to feel better if you want.
If you have a question, put it there. I’ll respond.
And you can click on my face
to subscribe to the channel.
Thank you so much and I’ll see you soon.